[موسيقى]
ولد في عام شهد كسوفا للشمس فكان ذلك
دافعا له ليصف هذا الكسوف في مخطوطه ترجمت
الى لغات عده
العالم الرياضياتي والفلكي والقاضي الشرعي
الاندلسي ابو عبد الله محمد بن معادن
الجياني
ولد وفق الراجح في العام
1989 في مدينه جيان الاندلسيه
لم ترد في كتب السير تفاصيل كثيره عن
بدايه حياه العالم الاندلسي ونشاته الا
انه تسلم منصب قاض شرعي في زمانه
ابرز الانجازات التي حققها ابن معاذ انه
اول عالم في التاريخ وضع ابحاثا في علم
المثلثات الكروي بشكل مستقل عن علم الفلك
هذه الابحاث ضمنها في كتاب سماه مجهولات
قصي الكره الذي يعد اول مخطوطه في حساب
المثلثات الكرويه بصيغتها الحديثه
كما كتب تعليقات وشروحات على اصول العالم
اليوناني اقليدس وفصلا في قانون الجيب
العام وحل المثلثات الكرويه باستخدام
المثلثات القطبيه
مخطوطاته الفريده كان لها بالغ الاثر على
علماء الرياضيات الغربيين
من مؤلفات ابن معاذ الشهير ايضا كتاب
انعكاس الضوء في الجو وكتاب جداول جيان
الفلكيه التي ترجمها المترجم الايطالي
الشهير جيراردو الكرماني الى اللغه
اللاتينيه
ولعل من ابرز عمل الفلكيه اطروحته العلميه
الكسوف الكلي للشمس التي ترجمت الى اللغه
العبريه
كما ان مخطوطته التي تصف انعراج الاشعه
الصادره عن الكواكب والنجوم حفظت في مكتبه
الطبيه
عاش العالم الاندلسي زهاء 90 عاما وتوفي
على الارجح في مدينته جيان الاندلسيه في
العام
1979 للميلاد
[موسيقى]